let's see who else we've got
holding let's try our caller from the
845 area code who's calling today from
845.
i think that's me how you doing david it
is david cadillac
david cadillac i like it all right
yes um i had a question for you
speaking of taking higher ground uh i
got a bit of an
anger problem most of my life and i got
it under control
but nowadays with all these ignorant
people you know walking around without
wearing their masks and
you know the regular moronic things we
see as normal people
i feel myself coming back to the person
i used to be and trying to avoid it
because i'm
so angry at these idiots i don't know
what to do about it
and speaking of taking the higher ground
i really appreciated your interview with
that um
jesse lee peterson guy made my day
it was so entertaining that i just
wanted to call
and say thanks for uh living everything
up a little bit
i needed it well i i appreciate that now
are you
so where i don't know if i hear like a
new york or maybe a philly accent there
where are you located that you're
dealing with these
these morons so often
the town i'm in is actually chester new
york okay
i worked in manhattan all my life so i'm
only a half hour away
okay we've seen the devastation here so
when you're saying you're getting mad at
people is it
are you getting in verbal confrontations
is it escalating to physical
oh it hasn't gotten physical yet but uh
they
are i used to be the person who would
agitate the fight
nowadays it seems like they have someone
nicely and they want to agitate a fight
so
you know i've done the right thing i
learned my life lessons i walk away but
at the same time i don't know how people
deal with these
with i just don't know it's not easy to
ignore but what is it sort of like you
ask someone to put a mask on and they
lose their mind or what's going on
lose their minds like literally like
crazy people i compare them to children
really because they lose you know
toddler fits is what it seems like
but they lose their minds police too i
got in a confrontation with a cop last
week
because he was in the store getting his
coffee next to me i said hey buddy
you think you might want to put a mask
on uh we're in a gas station
and he lost his mind i had to leave
because i thought he would just leave
and arrest me or something else
really so police what town was that that
police officers aren't wearing masks
indoors i thought the entire state of
new
york's had a pretty clear mandate on
that
i know well we say it all the time but
there's a line that you can report
people here in new york
and uh you know it doesn't do a lot of
good but
at least it's a step listen here's what
i would say because i understand i hear
the frustration and i would understand
it
the way i might try to resist the
escalations would be you know what
this is such a bigger problem than this
one guy or gal
that even if i go completely crazy and
change their mind
it's not actually i can't possibly do
that with everybody and so i
it's it's a sad realization but i would
take a more resigned view that really
this
the change in people's attitudes needs
to be systemic
and that you can't shout everybody into
submission and i would approach it that
way to try to not get too
uh you know hot behind the ears so to
speak
yeah that no that's absolutely dead-on
you know we just have to keep trying
to calmly as we all can and hopefully
change some minds
exactly and hopefully before we know it
there will be a vaccine we'll figure it
out
yeah all right my friend thank you i
appreciate the phone call appreciate it
thank you yeah great to hear from you
dave cadillac from chester new york
there
um okay let's go next to
our caller from the 720 area code caller
uh
where are you what's your name where are
you calling from
uh is that me yeah it is
uh my i'm aaron i'm calling from uh utah
actually
interesting i just had a question
regarding the uh
election coming up uh you've talked at
length about how you don't think
uh really the election interference is
gonna be too bad
and how uh the how he'll just leave
and no matter if he loses he isn't the
president well hold on a second let me
let's can we pause can we pause just for
a second there hold on i want to make
sure we're not mistaken so
i've not said i don't think the election
interference will be significant what
i've said is
experts who have looked at what trump is
planning
believe that each of his little tactics
will only have a modest impact and it
could flip the election to him
but if we get the turnout up the turnout
will do far more than any of trump's
tactics can do that so it wasn't it's
not so that it's
it's not going to be significant it's
that we know how to fight it which is by
overwhelming the vote and yes i have
said
i believe if trump loses he will go
eventually it may be under protest but
he will go
right i was more asking like do you
think anything like the 2000s
florida recount type stuff could happen
again yes
and that sways it sort of even though we
turn out
uh it doesn't work absolutely and this
is why i've said when we now you know
thinking back now
when we look at trump's supreme court
picks his judgeships
the fact that he's now starting to file
lawsuits against vote by mail
we need to run the score up we need this
to be
like an overwhelming win for joe biden
because the closer it is within states
or the closer it is from the popular
vote standpoint
it could provide cover for judges to do
very very bad things and if the results
are
very lopsided it just makes it more
difficult for a court
as an example to hand any state
any vote anything to donald trump and
that's why i think it's so important
that we have the biggest possible margin
in november we can't just win by a
little bit
we actually need to destroy trump
i agree i just wanted to see what your
opinion is thanks for taking a call
all right appreciate it thank you for
the call let's take a quick break if you
are holding please don't hang up
because after what is going to feel like
just an incredibly short break
i'm going to go right back to the phone